this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts  Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman this next  email comes from Dan from Prescott  Valley Arizona he said I hope to be  there in person for Kevin's holiest of  holidays but instead I watched Jay and  Silent Bob strike back same diff on this  for - honey I was wondering we get a  dramatic reading of because I got high  by afroman is done by Charlton Heston  it's an odd confluence of elements there  I got a shoot at though all right so  only ever happened once  all right Charlton Heston doing a  dramatic reading of the lyrics of  because I've got high by afro man I  haven't shot a movie in a few weeks it  feels good you're in practice I was  going to clean my room until I got high  I was gonna get up and find the broom  and then I get high my room is still  messed up and I know why because I got  high because I got high because I got  they're young  [Applause]  [Music]